um she met a lot to millions of people
she defined an era the queen's what
everyone says that's why her face beams
out from front pages across the entire
planet today literally every front page
of every paper in the world how many
people
could command that kind of respect and
detention
but sadly for all the good things that
have been said there have also been some
clueless cretins another word for them
who even a moment of shared grief is
just an excuse for them to
get out there and virtually signal their
abuse some so-called academics in
america and some journalists united
states using this moment to trash the
british monarchy and insult the queen
the most disgusting comments from
supposedly intelligent people one
academic academic
used the word loosely
wished her majesty a painful death
when she heard that she was dying this
is on twitter
she teaches people in america this is
all based on the idea that she was
personally responsible for colonizing
even genocide for the whole british
empire
first of all it's disgustingly
disrespectful on a day when so many
people are in mourning secondly it's
historically illiterate the queen ruled
the commonwealth of respect and
affection that's why the leaders who met
her loved her she presided over the end
of the british empire in doing so she
got independence and sovereignty to
millions
and lastly it's irrelevant today the
british empire's responsible for bad
things and some good things but all of
them happened a very long time ago
different rules different societies
different rulers a different age
we can debate the vices of virtues of
britain's history of course we can
but to those social justice stirrers
using a nation's grief
to burnish their worthiness i simply say
this get your facts straight
and show some respect